hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and today we're going to
be taking a look at another high
definition unboxing video and this one
is coming from dealextreme.com
for those of you who haven't heard of
deal extreme it's basically a site where
you can get a lot of neat tech products
and other things and gadgets for
extremely low prices hence the name deal
extreme either way today i'm not
actually unboxing a joby gorillapod but
an extremely inexpensive version of a
tripod that works with my hd camcorder
now i picked up this tripod for a single
digit number of american dollars and you
may even be able to find yourself an
extremely good deal that you might want
to check out over at the website right
now either way this is a very simple
unboxing and the only thing that you do
get in the bag is the tripod itself
so as you can tell this tripod actually
has a flexible head and flexible legs
making it pretty much the most versatile
tripod you can get for the money
now fully extended this tripod is about
10 to 10 and a half inches so if you're
looking to record something on your desk
or something very small this will be
perfect for that application but if
you're looking something on a larger
scale you're definitely going to want to
go with a larger tripod anyway mkbhd
signing out from a quick unboxing and
i'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace